you
hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar integration of
technology process and quality control
protecting complete sample chain of
custody
I am Alexis Krause of lab routes and
I'll be moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab birds and brought to you by Brookes
life sciences for more information on
our sponsor please visit Brookes life
sciences comm now let's get started you
can submit questions to the speakers
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your mind to do so simply type
them into the drop-down box located on
the far left your screen labeled ask a
question and click on the send button
well answer as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
if you experience technical problems
seeing or hearing the presentation just
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window or
report your problem by typing into the
ask a question box located on the far
left to your screen this is an
educational webinar and thus offers free
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located at the top right of
the presentation window and follow the
process of obtaining your credit lastly
at the end of the presentation you will
receive a survey which we kindly ask you
to complete your answers and suggestions
will help improve our webinar program
and are greatly appreciated I now
present today's speakers Andrew Brooks
babe ETSU Shawn Levy and Brad Hamilton
for a complete biography on our speakers
please visit the biography tab at the
top of your screen
dr. books please begin the presentation
great thank you very much welcome
everybody thank you for joining us today
I'm Andy Brooks I'm the chief operating
officer of are you city are pinnate
biologics and the chief scientific
officer for Brooks life sciences my
day-to-day work is around bio banking
services a lot like all of you that are
listening in today with a focus on
understanding sample quality control and
today's presentation and discussion is
really about managing the complete
digital and physical chain of custody
for the biological samples that we're
all responsible for I'm really delighted
and honored to have a tremendous panel
that can participate in this discussion
and everyone as you'll learn from the
brief presentations that are going to be
made comes at the field of bio banking
and sample quality and data quality from
a slightly different perspective we have
Fabe ETSU joining us who's the chief
scientific officer of the IEEE bbl/d
integrated bio Bank of Luxembourg say is
a world-renowned bio banker and
molecular biologist that has really
focused on the quality around bio
samples and has set industry standards
truly in the technologies and the
approaches that she's employed in
understanding sample quality we have
Shawn Levy who has of the who is at the
HudsonAlpha Institute Sean is a world
leader in sequencing based services and
technologies he supports several
thousand projects around the world and
Shawn's perspective really relates to
the use and quality of data and not just
data integrity but the quality of data
that is a function of the biological
samples that we collect and process and
present so understanding the role of
quality control and how it relates to
the data that we all work with once we
analyze these samples that are being
collected is a tremendous perspective
and our last speaker and panelist is
Brad Hamilton who is the co-founder and
chief scientific officer of life fold
bio Brad's company has a very
interesting perspective in the direct
consumer market in being able to respond
and react to the business and
lines of personal bio banking the
collection of samples by individuals
that want to store bio materials that
can relate to their own healthcare in
the future and as you can imagine the
quality of samples the quality of
samples associated with that kind of
activity is critical so today's agenda
we are going to be doing a roundtable
discussion and some of the discussion
points that we're going to cover through
a series of short presentations then
followed by a Q&A are a discussion on
biobank standards and how they impact
sample chain-of-custody sample
management the processing quality
control tools enabled harmonization and
how we can all work with samples in a
manner that allows us not only to
compare data but compare different
analyses as well as collaborative
biobank efforts and precision medicine
and what sample quality need means to
personal bio banking as well as
institutional bio banking managing the
sample lifecycle which is something that
Brookes life sciences has built their
life scientist pipeline around and that
we employ is really about harmonizing
biobank
essentials all the way from very early
times of planning your studies
facilitating sample collection
transporting that sample at the at the
right temperature with the right
timelines the processing of that sample
then the ultimate storage and
distribution of those those samples so
what's really critical is to understand
how all of quality control fits into
this process and I think one thing
you'll you'll find from all of the
speakers and all of the things that we
do as a community is that science and
technology is the true driver of
innovation by integrating sample
collection processing by integrating
sample collection and processing with an
eye on the types of analyses that we're
doing we can best protect those samples
and ensure that we're going to have the
highest quality data to do that we have
to
and what the future of sample analysis
is the technologies that have yet to be
discovered of the applications that have
yet to be investigated but we need to
create sample quality control metrics to
standardize across all collections so
that we're all operating from a similar
playing field as best we can
there are many opportunities for adverse
sample and adverse data collection
events to happen it can be at the time
of sample collection it can certainly be
at the time of processing of that sample
and as well as the time of storage of
that sample all of these processes need
to be regulated they need to be
harmonized across different programs so
that we can expect the same quality
irrespective of where we get our samples
of the way I personally look at it is
breaking these things down into what I
call the functional essentials how we
maximize biological resources all of
these slides will be available so we're
not going to spend too much time on any
one slide but the key points here is how
we maximally use each primary sample
making sure that the chemistry's and
technologies we use for processing are
maximally efficient as the samples that
we deal with are precious and limiting
we want to maximize the processing of
them defining appropriate storage
formats using the proper tubes the right
automation so that we handle the samples
correctly post-processing creating
renewable resources whether it's nucleic
acid amplification or cell line
establishment as Brad will speak to
later on and then also establishing the
right kind of governance the appropriate
distribution guidelines so that when
people request samples we provide what
they need to be successful and don't put
the rest of the collection of jeopardy
and and hopefully the theme that you
will hear throughout the other speakers
is how we need to integrate quality
control across all of what we do we must
implement technologies to evaluate
samples as a part of that omics central
dogma they'll hear Shawn speak to the
kinds of QC that's done to have be
absolutely sure that the samples that
they're working with and that data being
used is from the right sample and from a
quality sample we employ functional
quality control metrics so that we can
predict the performance of samples we
make sure that we employ technologies
that allow us not only to predict the
performance
to the sample but also the sample
identity and then harmonization of these
QC metrics so we can support global
collaboration and doing this real-time
is critical so hopefully that sets the
tone for the topic for today and I'm
really excited to participate the number
of my colleagues here and digging a
little bit deeper into these issues and
then have a question and answer period
that can get at your specific questions
so I'd like to turn it over to Faye
who's going to talk about some of the
challenges associated with the
harmonization of quality control that I
just alluded to okay okay thank you Andy
and Salo everybody from Luxembourg so
okay the question is why is the quality
of biomaterials and all their associated
clinical biological pathological pre
analytical data important to bio banks
into the communities that they serve now
as everybody knows there is a kind of
continuum in the processes between
research and industrial applications
with the output of one process being for
the input into another process and bio
banks provide biomaterials and
associated data to researchers at more
than one level in this continuum okay so
the first level is when bible's provide
biomaterials to researchers for
biomarker discovery and at that point
accurate sample provenance in terms of
clinical endpoint accurate identity data
in terms of demographics but also after
the pre analytical data in terms of
collection processing storage
information for the biomaterials are all
necessary to support correct
experimental planning with comparable
analytics and all this is necessary to
have well annotated to end fit for
purpose specimens also proper data
management is also needed for that now
on a second level by works also proper
biomaterials and associated ada took
industry for biomarker validation
and here are samples of different but
always well-documented pre analytics are
needed we can talk about the concept of
qualifies now when it comes at this
level
bodies are also to be used for
establishment of reference ranges for
new biomarkers and this point many bio
banks giving access to specimens from
different population groups are needed
and finally also biological resources by
biological resources you mean samples
plus data are used for method validation
equipment performance verification
method comparison and of course at this
point we talk about commute ability of
the biomaterials which is important in
biomaterials which need to be provided
in sufficient numbers and values now in
order to to control and to properly
document the chain of custody of the
samples and there is associated data
there exist quality management systems
and here you have an overview of
existing standards there is a new
international accreditation standard ISO
2387 which is recently been published in
August and compliant to these standards
shows consistency and competence of the
by bank there's a series of a European
accreditation send technical
specification standards you can see some
here on specific in the specific area of
pre analytics more of this is coming
this is an effort where the main driver
has been the European consortium spiria
and both clinical laboratories and bio
banks are in the scope of this document
next for the documentation and the
Thresher ability of the pre analytics in
a standard format the Eastburn has
published and twice updated the sample
pre-analytical code the spec and finally
when it comes to laboratory methods of
course as we know manufacture
instructions are always to be followed
but also I would like to add that there
is a new standard being developed a new
ISO standard which contains
specifications on the procedures that
can be used to properly validate a
laboratory processing method and biobank
repositories are in principle process
laboratory producing samples molecular
derivatives cellular derivatives as an
output he will have some more challenges
first one of our work is embedded in a
clinical diagnostic laboratory because
many bugs are embedded in clinical
laboratories and the primary focus in
this case of the business is of course
clinical diagnostic acids so processing
methods that are applied for production
of the samples which are in this case
the test items may be considered as
simply the pre analytical phase of a
clinical diagnostic assay and not is the
main process of interest there's also
the challenge of the interdependencies
between container processing analysis
what I mean is that a specific analysis
specific assay may be incompatible with
a specific processing kit and the
processing kit can be incompatible with
a specific tube container then we have
natural things relative to exploratory
methods and by exploratory method I mean
a method that the biobank laboratory has
never performed before or a novel method
that no one has ever performed before or
an adaptation or modification of a known
method visit in exploratory methods
represent a challenge we have in process
quality control materials that may be
needed to assess consistency in the
performance of a processing method as
you can see in the chart on the left
side this is a range chart and range
chart can be used by the processing
laboratory to ensure that the average
yield purity integrity other quality
attributes of the produced material is
consistent
we have also external Quality Assurance
programs for processing methods this is
the ETA processing schemes which again
are used to assess the performance of
the different processing methods and
they are especially useful when we want
to pull resources from different by
banks together and we want to make sure
that quality of the material is
harmonized and in all these areas there
are challenges relative to hook to the
homogeneity and the stability of
materials that need to be used either as
an improv excuse me
or than EQA materials there are
challenges relative to the nature of
this material sometimes surrogate
materials need to be used and to finish
I'd like to highlight one issue which is
the standardization in terms of quality
control of the different types of
specimens here I like to refer you to
this technical report published two
years ago by the Easter buy specimens
and working group and it's essentially a
guide to specific assays that can be
performed on specific types of specimens
in order to qualify them in the scope of
specific use or when this is not
possible
based on current knowledge in order to
stratify the specimens into predefined
quality categories and therefore the
user can make informed decisions on the
use of samples you know the best
experimental plant we've also put this
guide into the format of a free online
application we call this find my assay
this is so you can click and you can go
there this find my assay guide will be
updated in 2019 so to finish a lot of
challenges but also some tools to
overcome the challenges in order to
integrate the processing and the quality
control and to be able to provide
samples in which the users can have
total confidence and with this I would
like to pass it to dr. Shawn thanks Mae
so my name is Shawn Levine as as Andy
alluded to in the introduction my
laboratory focuses primarily on the
application of genomic assays to a wide
diversity of samples both in the
clinical as well as preclinical and
research space and I'll take the next
few minutes to offer some perspectives
that we find more on the laboratory
aspects and the integration of
importance of sample quality control as
well as sample integrity in that process
so as as I mentioned in the introduction
I oversee both the research and clinical
laboratories at Hudson alpha and we're a
center that supports a large-scale
genomic analysis for the
characterization
a number of diseases particularly
looking at both genetic and functional
variation and human development and the
ability to analyze and harmonize data of
course is critical in the number of
these efforts and as shown on the right
hand side of the screen over the last
several years the routine application of
genomics and large-scale studies has
become much more common and so therefore
the control of both batch and temporal
effects are important and very important
to be minimized at least as far as the
external effects go because many of
these things ultimately define the
resolution of the experiments and as the
technologies get better and better and
more routine to measure the totality of
the DNA or RNA species present it puts
more and more pressure both on the
quality of the sample and of course
highlights the critical importance of
the integrity of the sample with respect
to contamination and of course
appropriate sample identification so not
surprising there's a number of
procedures we've implemented including
large-scale automation as well as key
sample integrity management at isolation
and quality control and in brief summary
essentially all processes involved scan
and scan out process with integrated
barcode tracking and validation and the
use of what's now become fairly standard
in both the bio banking and research
space of 2d coded tubes and and then all
barcodes are of course are read and
tracked into a laboratory information
management system and an automation is
used whenever possible and then we
continued to perform isolations on a
plate based protocol with barcode
tracking what's shown on the left-hand
side of the slide is a part of our
automated in this case stool isolation
platform where it involves the what's
not quite visible as there's each of the
racks that are holding the taller tubes
that you see towards the middle of the
slide as those are those are entered
into the robot all barcodes are scanned
and in automated fashion in tracked and
then as the samples transfer into the
processing plates the 96-well place you
see towards the left of those tubes of
course those barcodes are are maintained
within an electronic database and then
and continue to track through the rest
of the processes and then when the tubes
are removed
this racks are taken out same thing
they're rescan to again verify that no
tubes removed inappropriately
during the asset aid we do the same
thing on all of the downstream on all
the downstream assays another important
factor after the isolation piece of
course is the continued tracking and
integrity measurement so this is just a
very simplistic view of two different
assays performed on the same sample when
an aliquot goes off for processing for
in this case it was whole genome
sequencing a separate aliquot goes off
for a fingerprinting assay and then via
our laboratory information management
system these the fingerprinting assay is
compared to the results from the whole
genome assay fingerprinting assay has a
little over a hundred highly or high
minor allele frequency single nucleotide
polymorphisms and then those are
compared to the to the final whole
genome or whole exome or even RNA
sequencing results and the expectation
is that you see an integrity score of a
hundred percent or 1.0 as you see in the
example samples shown here so this is a
kind of the first step in measuring the
integrity of the sample there's also by
because we sequence the fingerprinting
assay at very high depth it also allows
a measurement of contamination as well
at least to two reasonable degrees and
then finally as we've moved to more and
more automation we've also started to
assess the ability to perform higher
resolution quality and that that
involves the actual use of small
sequencing or rapid sequencing
applications if the endpoint assay is a
sequencing procedure that the
intermediate quality control and the
detection of molecular identifiers that
are introduced early in the sample
process whether they be spike in
identifiers or introduced during the
preparatory process those can be
measured and tracked at intermediate
quality control steps if those
intermediate quality control steps are
used you know use a sequencing
application which is kind of shown here
in a cartoon format on the left-hand
side of the slide that in this case some
examples of a one whole genome or even
same thing would apply to a to a whole
exome protocol that as samples go
through preparation and then are indexed
through some either PCR free or some low
cycles of PCR will then pull the samples
and do an initial assessment use
I seek instrument low-cost rapid way to
assess 96 to 384 samples at a time and
then from there be able to both measure
sample performance pooling performance
sample identity etc and then can verify
at this intermediate step before we move
on to higher larger expense or higher
expense assays that everything is
passing quality control and we even have
an opportunity to rebalance pools for
example if the distribution of the reads
per sample is incorrect for the what the
ultimate assay is needed to be so even
though there's a goal of introducing
sample integrity measurements
intermediate quality control
measurements and doing so at the
molecular level to enhance resolution
we've also taken an approach to really
ask the question as the technologies get
better and the resolution of the
technologies get better what additional
optimizations can happen at the sample
isolation stage to continue to improve
the quality of those samples for the
downstream assays and we say when I say
improve the quality of sample it means
try to get closer and closer to the
native state of those samples you know
in the in the cellular or tissue from
which they were derived so we've spent
some time on that in the last couple of
slides in closing I'll just show it an
example in this case this is from fixed
formula and paraffin-embedded sections
we have similar results from course
showing just quality improvement in
received RNA so about half of the slide
on the left-hand side was a standard
protocol where 22 out of a 95 samples
had a DV 200 of greater than 20% meaning
that the average nucleotide lathe
detected by fragment analysis was 200
nucleotides or larger it was only about
about a quarter of the samples past that
particular metric and I think our lab
like many others has found that samples
at DV 200 of 20% or higher generally
perform reasonably well and then through
an optimized protocol which we'll be
presenting more on and releasing in the
in the coming months we were able to
achieve nearly a hundred percent of
samples achieving the quality quality
value of above twenty percent and in
fact as you can see in the graph on the
right hand side
many of
samples now are actually exceptionally
higher-quality and this has not been
limited to one type of tissue or one
tumor type in fact this procedure
preceding the optimizations we had
probably isolated 20,000 samples under
these under these methodologies we've
isolated thousands of samples under the
optimized methodology and the this
improvement in quality is quite
consistent and actually a little bit
more striking in the core samples and
what this has the downstream effect on
is is a bit illustrated here and that
when we look at functional assays in
this case RNA sequencing assays we can
robustly manage the variation we see
batch to batch meaning that the the
nucleic acid material isolated performs
very similarly from one batch to batch
number two and in this case here this is
about 3,000 samples analyzed under the
same protocol and as you can see in this
or at least hopefully I can convince you
that this shows that the principal
component analysis showed the batch
effect the actual plate based batch
effect was in the fifth to seventh
principal component depending on how we
which group which samples we grouped
together and and then what's shown in
the black circles in the very middle of
the bottom panel is a positive
controller essentially a known control
that was included in each batch so in
closing you know the importance of
quality control and technical process
improvement through the entire the
totality of the asset we found that to
be critically important in addition to
some of the things that have been
discussed by the other presenters so so
with that I'll move on to our final
presenter
and thanks to everyone for their
attention thanks Sean as Andy mentioned
in the beginning I'm going to come at
this from a slightly different
perspective I'm a co-founder of a
company called my default bio which is
really delivering a personal bio bank to
consumers and we deliver that to
consumers off of blood with the idea
that we're preserving both the
informative as well as restorative
potential of blood ultimately for future
diagnostic and therapeutic uses so at
the end of the day we are in many ways a
consumer of the standards that Andy and
his group at Brookes established for our
processes so we like to see things at
the highest level possible
the
a direct-to-consumer company we focus on
preservation of actual cells DNA and
blood plasma from a peripheral blood
draw and as you can imagine there are
many many uses of the materials that we
isolate both from an analytic
perspective of the DNA contained within
but also the many biological and
metabolite components and things from
the blood plasma but also the cells for
an emerging use of cells in the
therapeutic space with that we obviously
want to make sure maintain and ensure
that we have high quality materials
preserved for our consumers and as you
can imagine within this process there
are really three points where
variability can creep in and
inconsistency can creep in and that's in
the collection in the shipment of the
blood sample likewise the actual bio
processing and the manipulation to
isolate the materials we want to
preserve and then ultimately in the
actual preservation and storage of that
so with that we will to actually control
that in a variety of different ways up
front on the collection shipment side
what we integrate to control that
process our contracted validated
phlebotomist that ultimately will follow
strict protocols in terms of how they
collect the blood into what types of
tubes they collect the blood into how
they ship the blood and package the
blood the next step in that process you
imagine we have to get the material
actually to the bio processing center
but get it in a stable way so we have
qualified and validated the actual
shipment protocols that we use where we
utilize FedEx is our primary overnight
delivery provider but we also do that in
a temperature regulated manner and then
last and very pertinent to our process
is actually having validated and
qualified bio processing and storage and
that's where we engage with with Brookes
life sciences and our UCD are to provide
and implement those standards practice
as you can imagine right consistent
process and long term stable storage are
actually very very essential for the
downstream use of the materials that
were storing for our consumers so if we
have low quality ultimately at the end
of the day the assays or the analytics
that people might want to engage
or the therapies they might might want
to engage with the cell-based or they'll
have inconsistent results they'll have
poor results or the given we're
collecting and preserving materials that
are going to be applicable on a
regenerative medicine or a precision
medicine base we know that sample and
process quality equals usability and
accessibility so we need to maximise on
our ends the compatibility with current
and even future assays so for example
what we currently collect and preserve
with our good self product which is our
direct consumer product is we preserve
the cellular potential in the white
blood cells that's contained within the
blood we preserve the DNA which is used
and obviously a variety of genetic
assays that are available both
direct-to-consumer as well as in the
clinical space and then the blood plasma
in the same context so if we have poor
quality of the DNA of the blood plasma
we're going to get inconsistent data and
things like that so with that
compatibility requirement for our
therapeutic processes and our analytic
processes we need to have standardized
consistent processes for what we know
today but what about the samples in the
future you know we know for example we
can run genetic assays on the DNA we can
run blood tests on blood plasma like
blood cholesterol blood sugars a variety
of things but we also know even
currently that there are different
components in those environments that
we'd like to detect so for example the
emergence of liquid biopsy or monitoring
cell-free DNA those are emerging areas
where people are understanding and
developing the way to properly analyzing
and and ultimately control the sample
for that analysis so you get consistency
those are being developed we currently
don't integrate those into our process
because we don't have a validated method
for that but what about the materials
for the future we're really it's about
you know are we collecting and storing
the right materials out of the gate and
if we're collecting them are we
collecting them in the best manner and
what's not known is not known so we
can't even store it in the best storm
format so with that we need to basically
work from an existing platform of
standard
process and that's with what we know and
we know we have validated measures for
qualifying the cells we preserve we have
validated measures for ensuring the
integrity and applicability of DNA and
downstream assay and we have validated
processes and and resources for the
blood plasma as well so really it's
about us working from a standard to make
changes in the future to evolve with the
science that's emerging and as new
scientific discoveries new end analysis
and things like that emerge and come
online we will adapt from that platform
and make the change from that platform
and not from some outside environment so
how do we deliver personal biobanking
responsibly to our consumer at the end
of the day the materials restoring are
for that consumer and for their use so
for us it's really about meeting the
needs and the specs of our partners that
we're reporting off of we are preserving
and storing the material and then being
the resource of distribution for that
downstream analysis or that downstream
use whether it's in therapy or analysis
so with that what we really want to do
is execute with the best partners in the
space we look to execute with certified
and accredited labs that are regulated
they utilize standardized processes and
methods highly automated highly
bar-coded we look to standardized
materials and use the highest quality
materials that need the highest level of
expectation for downstream use and we
look to use partners that have proper
management systems in place for us to
track and trace the consumers that we
bring on board and lastly and most
responsibly for our for our consumer
it's really about ensuring that they are
provided the most comprehensive proper
consent or and as alongside awareness
for all the potential future uses for
the materials that they're storing with
us to ultimately minimize delay and
utility down the line with providers
that are going to use the materials and
with that I'll pass it back they may be
and transition to the next part of the
program
great Thank You Brad I'd like to thank
Fay and Shawn as well for providing
their perspective and hopefully for
those of you that are listening in
you've got a little insight to some some
really different areas that require the
best in in digital and physical sample
Chain of Custody because as we all know
it really impacts everything we do
around the biological sample so with
that said now I think we will transition
into the really the roundtable
discussion with some questions from
those that are that are listening in and
participating and now I think you'll
receive a few instructions again about
how to post questions if you haven't
already done so and then we'll begin
thank you again and ladies and gentlemen
just a quick reminder on how to submit
questions just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and we will answer as many
of your questions as we have time for go
ahead Andy okay thank you so um
the first question I'd like to pose to
to Sean based on the question it's often
that you receive samples that come from
many different tissue sources and for
many different laboratories that
ultimately end up and I'm just
paraphrasing the question that
ultimately end up for one analysis for
another how do you really control and/or
address different tissue sources within
analyses or even different banks or labs
that are presenting samples so that you
can be sure that that data is as
harmonized or as homogeneous as possible
or is that not even possible well I
think it is within ranges and so
certainly probably like many
laboratories we have a series of
specifications that we request for
different tissue types and those include
of course a variety of fixed formal and
paraffin-embedded samples whether they
be cores or sections thick this is
section number of sections
proximate tissue area within those
sections etc as well as the the weight
of tissues for or cell counts for things
like fresh frozen tissue or sorted or
otherwise processed cells and so even
with it but of course within those
standards some percentage of samples
will meet them we know how the all of
the downstream assays perform within
those standardized ranges and so that is
one key step for the harmonization but
the reality is is that there's there's
always a number of samples that fall
outside of those ranges and when we look
at this from a patient perspective even
those samples that fall outside the
range they still represent of course you
know critical individuals whether they
be for research or certainly you know
patients that are looking for answers if
they're for clinical and so we still
have to have methodologies that can
robustly support things outside of those
ranges so we kind of call the range as
the ideal and kind of everything else is
still the workable we design and have
the assay goals and then so for things
that fall outside those ranges
harmonization is still an important
activity and the reality there that just
really shifts to instead of looking at
purely sample quality control it becomes
a continuum of specifications of sample
quality control all the way down through
you know the actual quality control the
data itself and then we and we really
just use operationally a series of flags
that indicate you know what Sam where
samples pass and where they may fail on
those different things so depending on
the question being asked across these
projects you'd have just different
tolerances of flags as far as that you
know that overall harmonization so that
the short answer is there there is no
short answer and that in the reality of
this space is that all of these samples
are precious they all represent you know
very important research value or
clinical value so we just do our best to
work with them and try to do so in a
highly documented and controlled manner
are there things that you can learn from
an analysis or the QC that you provide
on the samples that you get that could
be used to help individual sites
investigators or bio banks that are
collecting and managing these samples
there information that can flow in the
other direction to try and bring that
tighter given that there's only so much
that you can do once you get a sample
oh absolutely and we certainly make
those make those efforts I mean what
we've found in working with if I use if
I kind of take a section of oncology
based projects which often have you know
the highest number of challenging
samples because where the reality is the
molecular assays often get kind of the
leftovers from the pathology assays and
of course there's surgical procedures
and other things that can potentially
compromise as samples further is you
know we've we've tried to provide as
much feedback as possible and have as
much integration through the entire
sample collection process as possible
meaning that we're not just speaking to
the person who ships the samples out of
a biobank but ideally you know speaking
to the clinical staff even all the way
up through the surgeons and try to make
things as simple as possible and
understand their challenges to offer
some of those inputs and so we've tried
all of those things you know but the you
know again at the the summer answer is
as much information that can be passed
back to the effects of specific sample
compromises whether it be temperature or
time or processing as much as much clear
and distinct comments we can provide it
you know kind of if-then statements back
to those individuals we've actually been
able to see you know reasonably good
performance improvements for for a
number of challenging sample types
that's great thanks we have a question
that states or general question asking
where is the best place to find
information about the newest advances in
sample quality control sample
chain-of-custody
and the regulatory oversight of sample
collection and processing say given your
experience in the field and your
involvement in your role in not only
creating these approaches but educating
people and talking to the bio bank
community as well as the precision
medicine community where do you think
the best places to go for people either
basic or advanced to find where they can
get the best information about
chain-of-custody and quality control
I guess they're not too many places to
find the information is well when it
comes to management of samples of course
there is the International Society for
biological environmental or depositories
there there are several Easter indoors
courses that are delivered across the
world there are also national network
some of the National networks are really
active and you know continuously provide
information on the website the US the
the NCI the OB BR program in Germany the
German buyback alliance Spain is very
active Network Canada the city on net
network where people can find a vertical
updated information there is also the of
course the journal if you want to find
that up-to-date and latest news on
processing methods quality control or
method comparison so on fire
preservation and biobanking Journal and
of course other scientific journals and
this is of course it this is another
challenge in this in this community is
that the spread in terms of scientific
journals where one can find the latest
scientific information is so wide so
there are we one smooth looked across
with this working group and we could
find more than 150 journals where you
can find relative good for me so I guess
it's a one who should do PubMed helped
to be continuously updated because this
area is growing exponentially when you
look for a specimen research for example
10 years ago there was almost nothing
and now it to be grows exponentially
right don't you in your role at the IB
BL one of your programs you run a
proficiency testing programs for some
processing activities and quality
control
could you maybe share a little bit about
that and how that factors into this for
those that are asking questions about
how they can actively engage in
understanding the quality of the sample
on their process yes so we run this
biospecimen proficiency testing program
for the last seven years now so this is
an annual program where anybody can can
enroll online there is a group of
schemes which are processing scheme so
the participant receives a sample say
stabilized blood sample or an FFPE
sample which is previously all the
alphas have been tested for homogeneity
instability right so the participant
receives performs his routine extraction
method can be DNA RNA protein extraction
method can be viable cell isolations or
different methods and the product the
output is being sent back to ideal for
isochronous
central analysis relative to different
quality attributes of all these samples
that have been extracted or isolated
from each laboratory another statistical
analysis so each laboratory can see
adventurer mark the performance of its
processing method relative to all other
50 or 60 years
so whatever laboratories across the
world so this is the processing schemes
and there is another group of analytical
schemes where the focus is analytical
methods and these are now we are talking
we're not talking about clinical
diagnostic methods we're talking
strictly about analytical methods which
are performed to characterise and
quality control different types of
biospecimens so there are schemes for
the DNA quantification RNA integrity
cell viability tissue astrology and so
on and so in this case the participant
receives again a standard item in like a
reference material with an assigned
value reference value everybody submits
that the measurement submits online
results and then again
and see what is your the accuracy and
the precision of your analytical great
thank you it's a kind of education also
because in in case of discrepant results
there is identify so thank you pay the
next question relates to sample quality
control and data quality control in the
directed consumer applications or in the
role of personal bio banking so maybe
Brad you can feel this one is what are
some of the challenges that you face in
identifying quality metrics for samples
that you described were being collected
that you don't know what those
downstream applications are so how do
you best prepare for analyses and or
cellular therapies I guess in the case
of life fault how do you best plan for
that and how do you qualify those
samples and is that a question that we
can answer even though yeah I mean a
good question in itself right with the
emergence of cellular therapy in a
variety of different formats whether
it's blood stem cell transplant was
whether it's Carty therapies or the
emergence of you know IPS derived
differentiated cell product therapies
you know developing the standards of
what a qualified material is at the
endpoint is still being resolved and I
think is a little more resolved on the
upfront because what we're really
storing is the material to derivatized
off of we store the way we kind of
preserved potential and trying to
address the challenge of what we don't
know is we try and sort of minimize the
process with what we do preserve so with
what we break down we actually preserve
the PBMC layer which actually houses
three of the most commonly utilized cell
sources for their cell therapies right
now right so it carries I'm a deployed
for generators that have been used in
what stem cell transplant for decades
carries the T cells that are being
engineered and Andrian fused into
patients secure different
Foam is and leukemias and it also
carries the substrates of cells that
will be utilized to derive induced
pluripotent stem cells which are the
substrate for personalized stem cell
therapies so there are ways that we can
measure and monitor those so you know
some of the basic metrics that we apply
are simple things right can we secure
the right identity of the cell to the
best known standard that is published
you know particular marks for example
for Ematic waiting for generators you
know what's the viable cd34 cell
population for T cells we can utilize a
CD 3 a CD 3 mark or more specific subset
marks for IPS we actually go and we
validate the ability to actually isolate
the primary cell type that is going to
be the substrate for the reprogramming
process required to make these IPS cells
so we qualify the process to basically
establish that we then of course
quantify through different marks the
presence of that particular cell type
and then we validate the ability to make
a cell but at the end of the day you
know the utility of the materials that
were you know we're isolating better
known quantities their entry into
therapy is going to be defined and
specified by the companies and the
institutions that are developing those
treatments the unknown ones
general will continue to have you know
always the same challenges the identity
the purity and the potency
that's great Thank You Brad we have time
for one last one last question with
respect to transformed Transcom
transcriptome examples or transcript
profiling there's a question about
spikings and other controls Shawn maybe
you can maybe you can address this the
question with respect to transcript
profiling and metagenomic analysis so
whether it be fecal samples or RNA from
blood saliva what have you tissue what
controls do you recommend so that you
can assess both sample quality but also
performance of the assay and our
spikings used regularly for some design
spikings are used regularly it really
depends on the overall goals and so two
simple examples would be a
transcriptional profile and say a tumor
versus normal tissue which you know with
the goal of identifying transcripts that
hey there have functional significance
or have an ability to distinguish or
transcripts that could be used for
analyzing the functional consequences of
particularly mutations that may be
driving the cancer or even used in
assessment of therapy or residual
disease monitoring etc another example
would be say on the metabolic side or
microbiome side and looking for
transcripts that either in to indicate
the functional state of the different
species of bacteria that are present and
so in each case there they're generally
rooted in counting applications where
you're trying to determine the relative
amount of any given transcript that's
present in comparison to the relative
amounts of other transcripts either from
the same species or different species
you know depending on which one of those
applications now the spike ins can be
very helpful I think in two ways one is
they can be used for direct sample
integrity measurements and that is where
you just have a simple synthetic library
molecule that's spiked in where the the
segments of the insert on that library
molecule is unique to a given sample but
that spiking alone is great for sample
integrity measurements
and can be despite in a very very tiny
amounts on the prepara t'v process
because you don't won't need a lot of
reads to detect them on the downstream
side and certainly don't want to consume
a lot of resources from your assay and
testing those but it doesn't have any
measurement effect in terms of dynamic
range or overall measurements of
consistency in the assay and so then two
other spike in opportunities are
available one would be detected during
the quality control process where you
have a say a probe based assay that can
be detected during the real-time
quantitation of the overall libraries
those I think are not well used because
the complexities involved and the
variability in their performance at
least in our observations and the so the
other spike in which is probably more
valuable and more generalizable because
where you spike in a known collection of
transcripts in this case you would could
use them in combination with a sample
identity spike but they could also be
used completely independently where
instead of having a unique insert per
sample instead you have a dynamic range
of transcripts spiked in at different
levels where you can then assess within
a particular assay what is your lower
limit of detection your upper limit of
detection and then what is the linearity
of that detection in the overall assay
and then how those spikes are used so
for example prepared at the prepared
library stage would mimic or allow you
to measure the downstream sequencing
process if they were spiked in as
synthetic transcripts which again are a
little more expensive a little harder to
control but at least go through the
entire preparatory process have
significant value as well so you know
the end of the day setting up the
spiking controls can be complicated and
I think needs to be integrated into the
overall experimental design to be sure
that the appropriate measurements and
value will be derived from them and then
there's always of course the ongoing
overhead of those spikes so they have to
be continually evaluated to be sure that
they're you know they're giving an
accurate representation of the assay but
the latter example that I gave I think
is probably the most valuable and can be
most helpful in supporting assays that
have very wide ranges of detection needs
got it thank you we do have time for one
more question so I'm going to grab
another question from the list and this
question is about nucleic acids track
attraction DNA and RNA extraction and
the question is are there methods that
are standardized across sample types and
I'll address this question and take a
stab at it and the short answer is yes
there are methods that are standardized
for DNA and RNA extraction across sample
types and it really requires an
evaluation for the lab that's performing
this to understand what their metrics
are for success and in fact in my
opinion I think that there's still a
utility for using the four different
modalities for nucleic acid extraction
that exist and that would be either
organic salting out solid phase
extraction or be based extraction and
given your downstream analysis and what
you're looking for in your sample
quality you may choose one or the other
and then standardize across tissue types
or sample types so for example poor
investigators or people that are
interested in assays that require very
high high molecular weight DNA salting
out is the still the best approach and
if you're looking for those kinds of
those assays that's what you would
standardize against for your extraction
when you're looking at limiting sample
amounts people still work with more
organic approaches that may give you a
little more of a dirty sample but using
the right QC approaches you can predict
the the performance of that assay so in
contrast to someone that's doing
telomere length assays and salting out
to someone that's working with you know
very very small amounts of tissue and
just wants to get the most out they can
they may have a different approach where
I see the field gravitating towards our
bead based approaches in both research
applications as well as in clinical
applications and that gives you the
widest utility of extraction approaches
across tissue types so if you can use
the same
chemistry and modify the binding
conditions certainly your Lucian
conditions based on the amount of sample
that you have this gives you the
broadest success those approaches are
also amenable to being nucleic acid
agnostic if you will so you can look at
DNA and or RNA I'm not implying that's a
CO extraction approach but being able to
use the same chemistry and automation
gives you that precision and at the end
of the day you have to have an
analytical and functional quality
control assessment of your nucleic acid
to make sure that approach works for
your downstream application so it's not
just about you know the yield and the
purity but it's about the correctness of
the sample making sure that you test as
Sean had pointed out for sample
contamination as best you can and those
are the things in combination will lead
to the best standard approach claig acid
extraction
thank you again Andrew Brooks Fayette
sue Shawn Levy and Brad Hamilton for
your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank
laberd's and our sponsor Brooks
Lifesciences for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and for their interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today and those submitted during the
on demand period will be addressed by
the speakers via the contact information
that you provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on-demand through August of 2019
leverage will alert you via email and
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event a poll will now pop up on
your screen we thank you in advance for
participating until next time goodbye